so we're going to talk about the origin
the mathematical origins of Tetris
they're quite well-known computer game
and I thought about this because
recently I'm on a holiday in Crete as I
was walking down the side all these
people said in kind of Tara's rubbish
but there's this guy who's setting these
really interesting like math and logic
puzzles and click this one here which I
bought so this is a puzzle where it is
full of these elements here which these
are not quite Tetris because Tetris is
for squares these have 5 so these are 5
squares so these are all the possible
ways you can put 5 squares together
apart from this and rather brilliantly
so there are 12 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 there are 12 ways you can put 5
squares together and these are all the
possible ones and it turns out that you
can put them all together and there's
several ways to do it but they're quite
difficult to find you can put them in at
the square and all you need extra is the
4 by 4 so this is the sort of the runt
of the family well you can do it because
you know there are 12 and there are five
of these and so 5 times 12 is what 60
yes 60 and 4 is 64 which is 8 by 8 so
obviously you know the numbers are going
to work and it's just finding it and
again can it work and the reason why I
wanted to buy this is because there is a
person who is the first person to
discover that you can get all these
things with 5 squares and into a biggest
8 by 8 square and his name was Henry
dudeney or Henry Ernest dudeney known
his friends and friends as Ernest who
was Britain's greatest inventor of
puzzles I would say the greatest
inventor of mathematical puzzles the
world has ever seen
because the depth and the variety of the
mathematical puzzles that he did beat
anyone else and lots of Americans would
say no it was Sam Lloyd some Lloyd they
were contemporaries they actually hated
each other
well they liked each other than they
femme at so they hated each other
whereas Sam Lloyd probably did more
puzzles was a bit more of
salesman and he also did some amazing
puzzles but you don't find many
mathematicians studying samlloyd puzzles
but you find still there are also
dudeney puzzles that people are
interested in including this one here
and this one first appeared in 1907 in a
book called the Canterbury puzzles which
all have had historical stories to them
and the story was so willing the
conqueror he's the person who came away
from France and my invaded England then
became King of England and he had two
sons and his sons went to France and
stayed with the son of the French King
at the time it's kind of just sort of
slightly apocryphal history and
apparently got into a fight and the
fight was over a game of chess because
the British were beating the French
blows were given basically obviously I
started fighting and the chessboard was
quite over the head of someone and
collapsed into thirteen different pieces
and the thirteen different pieces that
are drawn in the 1907 canterbury puzzles
are exactly these pieces and this is the
first time in the mathematical
literature that you have the selection
of all the possible shapes that you can
get when you put five or in fact any
number of squares orthogonal next to
each other so I think that they've got
to be either straight on dudeney also
did another puzzle ten years later which
was all about stamps and folding stamps
and they said what are the different
ways you can tear out four stamps
together and that was the first time
that there were ever the appearance of
Tetris blocks because if you have two
squares together
that's what Tetris is and so dudeney the
first time ever he did any type of block
were the five ones and oh seven and then
a 17 there were the four ones now in the
1960s this American mathematician called
Solomon Golomb started looking at that
and starts to classify them and do lots
of maths on them and he starts to call
them polyominoes so the five one are
pentominoes and this is the set of the
five of the 12 pentominoes there are
tetrominoes which are the ones with four
and they're the trial minoes
and then there's the Domino's - the one
with the - and it was because of Solomon
golems work in the 1980s a Soviet
computer guy was reading golems work
with golems work references do Deniz
work and basically invented tetris
tetris which is the tetrominoes falling
knew how to stack them and i'd know this
is basically if it was called petrus
this is basically what it would be like
I've got this because of the horror the
historical nosov it I thought isn't it
interesting that this is the very puzzle
that began Tetris and Here I am in
Greece and the guys selling it and so I
bought it and it is incredibly
satisfying to do so it would probably
takes me each time can you will forget
how you stack them and each time you do
it it probably takes me about 15 20
minutes and you think until you've done
it there's no way I'm gonna be able to
do it
and then when you get it you just do get
it and you sort of work out little
techniques you know these ones here like
much more complicated as quite good to
put that there and also there's another
one this one here gets in the way so I
can often start with something like this
maybe let's put this in the corner it's
so sort of tactile and it's lovely and
when you get it it's really really
really satisfying we've made a second
video about another famous dudeney
puzzle what I want I want you to get
them there to hear in three moves also
if you'd like to see more videos with
Alex bellos or buy one if it's excellent
books about mathematics including this
one about puzzles there'll be a link
down in the video description thanks to
everyone who supports numberphile on
patreon like the people whose names you
see on the screen if you'd like to join
them also there'll be links down in the
description oh and here's the solution
pretty easy